despite Russia's suspension of its part
in the deal on Saturday the Black Sea
grain Corridor has remained open for
business recently departed ships full of
Ukrainian produce waiting for inspection
of Istanbul the United Nations and
turkey working hard to restore Russia's
participation and confirmation of
success came in a message handed to the
Turkish president mid-speech
Russian defense minister Mr shoigu
called our National Defense Minister
hulusiakar and expressed that the grain
transports will continue as agreed
before as of 12 pm today
[Applause]
Russia stopped its cooperation after
this attack on its Black Sea Fleet in
Crimea on Saturday it alleged it had
been launched by Ukraine at least
partially from within the grain Corridor
Ukraine denies using the corridor for
military purposes and has neither
confirmed nor denied it was behind the
attack
we demanded assurances and guarantees
from the Ukrainian side that nothing
like this would happen again that the
humanitarian corridors would not be used
militarily our Turkish Partners mediated
our defense Ministry has received
information from the Turkish side that
Ukraine has given such assurances
Vladimir Putin went on to say that
Russia reserved the right to withdraw
from the deal again in the future if
Ukraine went back on such assurances but
that it would not impede Ukrainian grain
from reaching Tokyo here in Kiev a
senior advisor to the Ukrainian
president said Russia's escalatory
threats and blackmail had failed because
the deal had been shown to work even
without Russian involvement
Turkish side was totally one Ukrainian
security analyst says an important
element was takia's leverage over Russia
[Music]
continue for the Russian Federation to
Target Turkish ships would be uh the
last probably uh decision the most
um the least beneficial uh so that is
definitely influence their readiness
but few expect plain sailing Russia had
been accused of deliberately slowing the
inspection process at Istanbul something
now possible once again the deal is due
to expire or automatically renew if none
of the parties objects on the 19th of
November Harry Fawcett Al Jazeera Kiev